how do you find the energy to not only
play chess which is also which is quite
hardcore but also stream let's go on
YouTube do your videos and play entitled
Tuesday as well well I like it like I
said um and I've said it before but I
think um you know I do consider myself a
streamer first all this other stuff I
consider it's something that I've been
doing non-stop for the last three years
pretty much
um and playing chess is rather rather
strange it's not something I've been
doing for for the last three years so
um you know I think mainly it's just my
enthusiasm for chess I've always had it
and I think certainly for me because I'm
not playing that many classical games
it's it's actually quite exciting to see
these positions in these various
openings on the board whereas you know
if I was playing in the grand chess tour
and all these other events I probably
would have seen like 20 Berlin's over
the last month and a half and I'd be
sick of Chess so it helps a lot that um
that I'm able to do all these different
things